[Music]
this was a book first and how did this
project get turned producer writer which
came first who was who found the
material and who found the writer I
found the book there was a kid in my
office who had heard about the book and
he pitched me the one-line idea you know
it's kind of a beautiful kind of
fragmented love story coming-of-age
dealing with a kid who drinks too much
and it's probably r-rated and I said
that's not what anyone's making I think
it was literally like the weekend at
Twilight it was like about to open or
something like that and I thought well
geez that's not what I you know
films are not being made that way but
then the next morning I was flying to
New York and at LAX there was the book
sitting in the bookstore I thought it
kind of was kismet so I bought the book
really knowing just nothing other than
just kind of the idea of what the story
was and I fell in love with it and I
landed and I remember I called my office
said I have to make this into a film and
then it was okay we need a writer and
then we kind of submitted the book out
to every studio mini major and
independent financier in town and
everybody passed and it was a writer who
was a brilliant book by Tim Tharp who is
a college professor in Oklahoma I have
to give credit to Jeremy Steckler who
was a young executive at Searchlight at
the time who said you know what if we
give it to Scott and Mike and I knew
Scott and Mike kind of socially and I
met them before and there they had
written the script that I fell in love
with everybody else did too called 500
days of summer they read the book in 24
hours which never happens and they said
yeah we want to do it and so literally
that that took all of the onus off of me
because then the onus was on those guys
the challenge here was that the novel is
very much it's a first-person narrative
it's very much from the perspective of
this character and you're in his head
the whole time and he's talking to you
and and what's really beautiful about
the book is that about halfway through
you start to realize that the way he
sees himself isn't exactly the way
everyone else sees him and and we just
said that's cool how do we figure that
out in screenplay form and we didn't
want to do a lot of voiceover and we
didn't want to do a lot of that kind of
thing that would get in your way so we
just put it out there hoping
to someone awesome would come along and
be able to film it in that way and and
yeah so we were you know we're super
excited way it turned out
we heard that Shailene was going into
meetings and that someone would say
Eileen right have you read anything good
what do you like and she'd be like I
read the script called the spectacular
now that I loved and and when I heard
that when that got back to me I was like
how do we meet her like you see the
descendents we gotta get on that she's
amazing and um that was really an
important sort of thing because it sort
of got the ball back rolling I people
were we're like what is this script
Shailene loves it it must be good and
let's read it and that helped get it off
the table because I think it had been on
the shelf for for a couple years being
like oh that's that thing that's never
getting made I had heard of Tim's novel
because it had been nominated for the
National Book Award but I hadn't read it
but I just never imagined that I would
want to direct someone else's script but
I did read it and it was the fastest
thing I've ever read there fantastic
writers and what really blew me away was
the Sutter I mean I had always been
interested you and I were talking before
about the you know the up who films and
then fontanelle films from Truffaut and
I'd always wanted to write something
that took place in high school that was
vaguely autobiographical but I could
never quite wrap my head around it and
then the script presented itself which
really Sutter was kind of me at that
point my life and really what he's
dealing with is a lot of what I was
dealing with at that point so when I met
with them what I presented them I came
in with I think it was like a 60 page
look book of exactly because as you said
it really is a tight rope well there's
just not very many films that are I mean
teen film quote-unquote teen film is
sort of a marginalized film ghetto or
you assume it's going to be adolescent
its value system it's going to be about
TNA it's gonna just it's going to be
going for low-hanging fruit and there
are for me so in that look book sort of
that really defined the tone and exactly
what's going for it sort of connected
the dots that I saw in what is a
immature romantic r-rated drama where
the characters just happened to be
teenagers to other films like last
picture show and splendour in the grass
and east of you can rebel without a
cause and say anything some of the films
of the 80s from Cameron Crowe and then
we're just very and I you know was very
clear I want to shoot this on anamorphic
35-millimeter I want to shoot in Athens
Georgia where I'm from the
takes place in Oklahoma we talked about
actors and shaylen's interests and it
really was also something that was
profoundly exciting to me because that
was sort of a barometer for what the
value system of the film would be which
is you know her performance of the
descendants to me just it just
completely lacked any vanity and was a
fiercely intelligent and brave
performance and she reminded me of like
a young Debra Winger [ __ ] Spacek
so oh it just was like if we can sort of
populate this film with an ensemble
around her that's that good we might
have something they treated the
characters like adults and there were
they weren't stereotyped into one
certain category and I don't know it was
it affected me when I read it I cried
when I read I laughed when I read it and
I knew a Sutter in high school and I
knew an ami in high school and my
experiences in high school were similar
to what a lot of these characters were
going through and I felt actually there
was a scene that doesn't make it doesn't
make the movie but when I kind of like
take the microphone and it's just that
very much like look at me there's a
scene I'm at prom and we've been you
know making out drink a little bit and I
grab the microphone and I really just
try and like DJ the the prom and a
what's up and I think I even started
like freestyle rapping about the Sutter
Mann and this and that then I end up get
kicked out but that was a weird that
just like that a center of attention
kind of thing but what I was most
excited about with this character was
because I've done a few party movies I
guess I've played kind of a charismatic
you know life of the party kind of guy
before but just all this stuff like with
my dad and with especially once Kyle
inhabited that person that stuff was a
lot of fun to shoot but anything would
Shailene was such it was really easy and
I don't mean that in like a lack of you
know you know respect for the work or
anything but Shailene we just I don't
think either either of us were
necessarily trying to steer a scene at
any given one and it was just very
natural it's like a lot of the stuff a
lot of the you know just little moments
and the little improvisation we do
that's just because I think we were just
right there I was expecting him to be
like a quiet introverted little soul
like he was in rabbit hole and
that was not at all miles teller I think
I just got back from Vegas yes we had
great conversations about Vegas and GMOs
and just had uh chemistry we had a great
lunch and then after the lunch
Shailene talk to me about GMOs for
literally private forty five minutes an
hour and I just I was taking all in I
called my mom it's like mom do you know
about this GMO thing these are terrible
for you
something about corn and it's just not
as good as you think mom I check this
out let's Shailene really enlightened me
but she continues to do every time we
hang out it's not in the movie but in we
did film some scenes where she's has
sort of a abusive whether physically or
not but mentally abusive stepfather and
there's a scene where she sort of talks
about kind of being molested a
fourteen-year-old by her stepbrother and
so there was there was a lot of things I
didn't make the movie but we did film
that sort of laid heavily on Amy and I
didn't I never saw her as a victim to
those things I saw or somebody was like
okay those things happen to me and I'm
gonna continue moving forward I'm going
to climb the cell and I'm going to get
to the other side and I'm gonna get out
of this town I don't know how I'm gonna
do it but I'm going to eventually do it
even if it's in ten years and I think
meaning Sutter was really important for
her because he ultimately was the kind
of list that made her stand up for her
mom and made her move on with her life
but in our first meeting I was like if
you see her as somebody different than
that that I'm not that girl because I
don't personally believe in being
victims to our circumstances and I I
just I definitely don't see that for her
and James was obviously in full
agreement and opened my eyes to so many
more things about her that I hadn't
thought about and I think that making
that choice now having watched it sort
of just added another layer to their
relationship and the dimensions of their
relationship because even though she is
I never always saw her sort of a strong
person however quiet and shy she never
had the strength to fully stand up for
what she believed in and that's one
thing that he helped her with which I
think was is really profound and even
though the relationship is so incredibly
toxic in a way and very unhealthy and
breaks her
and breaks him down emotionally I think
it's kind of important for young adults
to go through that process I went
through it when I was in high school to
sort of lose yourself in a way to
someone else because after you're
finally finished with that little
journey you're able to go on your own
journey and figure out who you are and
so at the end of the movie I kind of
think that that's where she is whether
you know she takes him back or she
doesn't which is everyone always wonders
you know what we think about that but I
think it's sort of I think that I hope
that she's in a place where she's able
to regain some of her own
self-confidence from her own self-worth